that's what they all said this is what
they all said
and i've got 17 of them you're next you
call me dave you call me
phil because it doesn't matter anymore
you're not gonna remember tomorrow
you don't remember what my name is
tomorrow
um what's up guys
monday again we came around again we're
back welcome back welcome back
um guys yeah patreon as always
um this week you know what i'm gonna
give you a break we pushed the 30 30 as
far as it was ever going to go
um so i'm going to give you guys a break
you know what's right in your heart
yeah you're we're all adults here we
don't need to tell you right from wrong
you know what's right in your heart and
if you don't want to do right by us then
that's fine i can't force you
we'll leave it there in it link's in the
description if you're feeling um
giving and then you want to enjoy some
more content that's fine
um that's all good obviously guys um i
haven't really spoke about it for a
while but obviously the merch
doesn't stop flying
that's why we don't push it that much it
just doesn't stop flying
that's hilarious the most literally
doesn't stop flying it doesn't matter
i don't understand it monthly month out
it's just cute
thank you so much um yeah bro it's all
good paypal is it's just hot in there
yeah it's healthy hey
so obviously jump on the merch if you
want to join the crew links in the
description
uh guys if you liked the video for the
love of god like the video
this is the week let's get to a thousand
likes
if you can pour for four pour for four
civil play den mandela
yeah a thousand likes 1k likes that
would i'd have a heart attack
i'd be so excited i'd have a heart
attack 1k likes see that k on the like
ting i'll be guys shut your mouth i'll
be gassed
thumbs up 1k thumb up 1k no no no no no
no that's too much yeah source out so
please guys yet
um see what we can do about that if you
please um
obviously jump in the comments um as you
can tell we're replying to as many
comments as we can at the minute
um hope you're enjoying guys give us
your input hit us in the dms
instagram the twitter um if you like the
smooth mellow voices in your ears uh
leave a review
on whatever platform you listen to the
podcast on um
and always guys if you didn't already
know
this week's episode is brought to you by
man scooped um so guys we've all been
there
but i've used the same trimmer on my
balls as i have in my face i had to do
it i didn't know there was a second
option i had to do it bruv
who's got two trimmers i can tell you
for a fact
now yeah i've never done it he's done it
he's that easy
he's fine it's fine fiora doesn't want
to own up it's fine guys if you
[ __ ] you might know it's okay i've
never done it you've done it i've never
done it and
[Music]
you shouldn't be doing it guys obviously
if he doesn't want to own our baby
shouldn't be doing it that's hilarious
and i
know that now we shouldn't be doing it
so guys um
it's disgusting um mindscapes are here
to help you out guys so if you head on
over to manscape.com
discount code sng for 20 on and free
shipping that's discount code sng
manscape.com free shipping and 20 off
guys
go enjoy right tools for the job now
come on let's fix up we can we're better
than this
2021 we're better than this yeah we are
so it's it's
here for you guys man yeah we're gonna
use it for you guys no more upsets
downstairs bravo no more same z's
make sure you use that discount again
yeah man all right guys uh before
anything else yeah jump in all right
today's fun fact was actually sent to us
by a fan
because um so you may have seen it i'm
not too sure in the emails
um so an ex-psg player jean-pierre adams
has been in a coma for 39 years after
receiving an
anesthetic that was meant to keep him
out for a couple of hours
so he could have surgery on his knee
this was in march 17th
1982. he's still in a coma and he's 73.
i'm gonna read a bit more information
about it so adams and his wife
bernadette were married in 1969 they had
two sons
following his ligament rupture injury he
was hospitalized was
um for surgery on 17th of march 1982
um at some hospital in leon after an
error made by the anaesthesis
and i can say the word anaesthesis
[ __ ] out
he suffered a bronchospasm which staffed
his brain from oxygen and he slipped
into a coma
in the mid-1990s when a court law
when a court of law adjudicated um on
the case
both the anesthesia and the trainee were
given only a one month suspended
sentence
and the fines translated to 815 his wife
continued to tend to his needs
refusing to consider euthanasia mad
quick meeting coma
fam a footballer for a knee injury
slipped into a coma that's our everyday
job
into a coma bro been in a coma for
year decades i've always wanted to when
i want to get my wisdom teeth out
i've always said knock me out these
might need to knock me out
because i don't want to be there awake
while they're just ripping teeth out my
face
and i've always said knock me out and
people always say bro you'd
get knocked out ain't the one you know
is actually not the most dangerous
it's dangerous i'm fairly certain uh i
don't really talk to my dad about this
stuff
but i'm fairly certain my dad's mom my
nan died
from uh complications with um
anesthetic really after the surgery
oh man yeah i haven't gotten into any
details with him about it okay yeah yeah
because that's that's yeah yeah
but i'm pretty certain that's i think
it's at my mum time i'm pretty certain
that's what happened
um so yeah these things these aren't a
joke bruh getting knocked out ain't the
one
but i've always just been like help me
out for any routine surgery
knock me out damn but yeah that's crazy
imagine
i couldn't he ain't waking up i couldn't
imagine that the wife is strong
she is the wife is strong i would
sue everybody that's the thing as well
it's a tough one as well because it's
like
obviously the doctors it seems like they
got like a slap dash fine and stuff like
that but then again it's
like is it obviously i don't know the
details was it their fault and even if
it was their fault like how much
are you allowed to account for human
error because as a medical errors are
through the roof
but the amount of deaths a year due to
medical errors
are high are high i don't know what the
numbers are but they're
[ __ ] high bro hi um
people die from medical errors all the
time is that how much accountability can
you put on that person and obviously
you've got doctors who work like 20 30
hour shifts
and you've got like all sorts of things
trainees um
so it's like how much accountability can
you put on a person when there's such a
thing as human error
human hair i i make mistakes at work
every day
bro yeah yeah every day gdpr
what's that what's that i break i send
emails to the wrong person
all the time
i send the wrong email all the time
hilarious i'm tired
i'm tired and i'm supposed to understand
all these little drips and drops that
need to go in to knock people out enough
have that hold that add that is he out
yes fine
it's fine this is fine um that's jokes
yeah bro
that's but that's horrific imagine i
couldn't imagine rooty knee surgery
supposed to be out for a couple of hours
man's still down now years later
decades later he's old now imagine
waking up and looking in the mirror
imagine waking up and looking in the
mirror he's gonna wake up
not knowing what kovid was not knowing
what year it is not knowing if he's
where his wife is or who he's
you know he's going to got to know what
24 he'll see his wife and think who's
this old [ __ ]
get your scabby hands off me brother
where's my wife she's gonna wake up with
the wife's hand and just be like what's
that
what's me and she's just they're like oh
joel yeah
it's more about that
get away from me ah his legs won't work
muscle memory gone put me back under if
i woke up and
and that was that put me back under
paraplegic for days oh hundreds
one hundred recipes
yeah yeah he's done for that's such a
shame he is
porting that's dread that's cool fun
fact though
very interesting it's very scary um
it's not fun it's a fact but it's not
fun yeah there's nothing fun about it
but yeah jesus christ that's deep
um right anyway would you rather would
you rather
fart every time you get a hard-on
or bust nuts at random
how random is random bro like any time
it doesn't matter if i'm clothed any
time anywhere
even when i'm soft yeah bro you are
okay in this scenario you get hard like
you you probably get a five second
warning
because you get a but like you get a
boner
and then you just ah here we go yeah but
that's double on that's not double
entendre that's [ __ ]
um double poison because if i get a
boner then i'm gonna fart
nah because you're either fighting or
busted if you've chosen to bust nuts at
any time then you're not gonna fart when
you get back okay okay okay okay okay
um how far whilst i've got a boner
or boss nights at random yeah um so
every time you get hard is it is it just
the one fight i do whilst i'm hard for
that one time
yeah as soon as you get hard you fart
okay uh i would
probably have to go for the nut bus
really i think so oh i think so purely
because
like we spoke about this before like
sometimes you just get bonus in the
morning like there's like
the what's what the what's the
terminology you
you said there's a a um chemical boner
and like a
oh sexual about a satellite yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't know
for for context when you wake up in the
morning sometimes you need to piss
your dick is kind of hard because it's
hard it's like you're holding it yeah
yeah yeah
and then obviously there's an arousal
burner so
if i wake up in the morning and it's
just that bone and i fight i couldn't
give a [ __ ]
yeah but if every time anyway in the
morning exactly yeah i'm about to
have sexual relations with my woman bro
yeah every time your lips up your missus
it's just
fun yeah
but imagine imagine
if you're in like a long-term
relationship if she firms it at the
beginning
do you reckon it could ever just like
turn her on
because she's so used to you farting
every time you get hard that she could
just be
she could just be watching countdown and
she's like
and she smells like must and she's like
ugh but then she's thinking
he's horny she knows it's like the dog
in the belting yeah
for food she smells pop and she's like
um
no i reckon she'd leave my ass oh 100
she'd leave my ass
yeah it'd probably have to be the nut
bust you know because
every time i hire up i'll sign up
prematurely is that what you said no you
just bust
i just busting up randomly sorry yeah um
i think i'm going to choose that yeah i
think i'm going to choose that because
the
the fighting every time you get hard is
i don't know i don't think that's that's
not
that's not kosher for her i can deal
with that yeah yeah
yeah but you're [ __ ] myself do you
know yeah true um
i'm probably gonna choose the fart one
you know there's busting out a random
thing is just like
bro like boston like it's intense you
know i know it is i'm just writing
and there's just [ __ ]
to be fair i'm sweating afterwards i
don't want to i want am i wearing
diapers bruv am i wearing adult diapers
all day
oh because then and i look and all my
boxers are just
cracked they're just hard stale starchy
boxes
starchy's the word starchy is the word
and i'm just like what is this bro and
then like what if you're trying to get
into relations your woman's like oh
tonight's the night and you're not babe
i'm not gonna lie i've noticed seven
times today
i haven't got it in me my balls are
aching bruv
my balls are aching she's like come on
man it's been two weeks you know babe
i'm sorry
it's a busy period for me right now i
don't know what's going on i'm busting
all the time
oh
oh i've not thought about but the pup
thing it depends if i i think like if my
diet is clean if i just have to make
sure i keep a clean diet
and then if i'm fighting every time i
get a boner like hopefully something we
can deal with
if your diet is clean it's gonna be it's
not gonna be that bad yeah that's what
i'm saying
and then maybe i could just have tactics
like
we're under the covers lips and lips and
lips and i'm gripping and then
i'll pop and then i just give her
i give her without knowing
just blow out the back and i'm like
let's go your battery's facing that way
her back is facing out so your lips in
you fight you just lift up the tigs yeah
yeah i just got my cheeks
out in the open hopefully you must stop
that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah distracted
lips are up i'm just flipping it lips
are up and
her she's like what's never mind and i'm
just like i put my my hand over the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] the [ __ ] up she's like
kinky
kinky yeah i don't know i think i'll go
with the fart one i don't want to but
i don't i couldn't just be busting nuts
all the time i don't know
that's a tough one that's a good one
that's a good one made me think a lot
more than i thought
yeah well that's another one that i read
i thought what the [ __ ] even is that
yeah and then you actually discuss it
like jesus this is tough
it's difficult man and it's disgusting
like i wouldn't want to do that
discuss this i wouldn't want to do
either but yeah i'm going to stick with
my ass up even though
after you describing having busting nuts
seven times in one day
that's that's hell that's i don't i've
never done that i never want to do that
um but [ __ ] i don't know man
bro it's a weird one because like it
would it would then start [ __ ] with
you mentally
where you're actually in the in the love
making act
and then when you feel like you're
getting close it would feel like oh no
no no do you know what i mean even when
it's the right time you'll be you'll be
having like
mixed emotions about like should i even
be busting right now or is it going to
happen by accident is this a natural one
there'll be so much anxiety around the
feeling of about to knock
that's too much to deal with that's the
best feeling of all time you don't want
to ruin that
true true yeah busting nuts won't be
special anymore it's nothing now it's a
torment for you
ah i didn't think about it you never
want to have sex again
didn't think of that i might have to
switch it to the farting
quick pop done
poopsy whoopsie breeze it out and you're
fine
please if i've had a hefty meal that
days long oh you can't go out to eat
it's long for her bro i've had a curry
oh
she knows it's a wrap we're not [ __ ]
done we're not [ __ ] it's she's
wrecked but i can't help it if i get
horny
if we're cuddling for canoodling it's
your fault babe and i just get a little
hard on
oh she's smelling that it's long ah
she's so annoyed at you all the time
she's gonna break up with me in a
heartbeat
yeah right in a heartbeat right so my
ever never gonna have a wife again
or i'm gonna have a wife that that you
can never please you can never please so
i'm never going to have a wife again
yeah yeah yeah it's a loser it's a loser
but i will change my mind to the to the
14th because think thinking about
busting seven nuts in one day
i'd rather top myself because i've been
i think the
nut four five six and seven will be
blood
they won't be seen man they'll be pure
blood because i i don't i can't produce
that anymore bro my sack will be
empty the most rounds i've ever gone in
a day
with a female is literally like six or
seven
and this was when i was young in my
prime and even then it was against my
will
and the last few words the last few were
torture
i couldn't i remember on the sixth one i
think i fell asleep inside
i just dropped i just collapsed i
couldn't see but i can't anymore
so i can't anymore ah that's one thing
that's the
well i don't women can go a lot longer
than men
but obviously i think the only thing is
that they just get dehydrated obviously
men do get dehydrated as well
yeah but if you can't produce that
sensation of wanting to bust or not
it's a pointless occasion oh 100
pointless 100
if she doesn't not she still has the
sensation of the feeling
yeah if i'm hard after like if i'm hard
and i'm [ __ ] you for the
fourth time in a day it's agony
you know actually actually eggs yeah
yeah
actually eggs and i i guess the same for
her her [ __ ] old [ __ ] will be sore but
i don't know she's a trooper you said it
was against your will so she she was
clearly down for him she was down now
that was tough
that was a tough day i know he was i
think i know he is
um firstly first year uni yeah no
no no no oh you're thinking about the
time where it was just
eat sleep yeah that was like three or
four rounds oh good
this one was um
be no way yeah yeah yeah no way
in the all your man we're in the yard no
way yeah
okay would not have expected that yeah
yeah fahren i i can understand why you
want seven to be fair uh
now i don't know who it is i could
understand i said against my role it was
against my while i was tormented but i
hated it i literally hated it
damn yeah it was horrible but anyway um
that is you said you had a topic for us
today um it's not necessarily a topic
it's more
i've got two little segments here little
things you know the word
scent right like the smell yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so
s-c-e-n-t yeah yeah which letter do you
think is silent
or the s or the c because s-e-n-t
is sent yeah c-e-n-t is sent as well
do you know the answer are you just
asking me no i'm asking the audience fam
um i don't know if either of them are
silent to be fair
okay i think it's just part of the
pronunciation
scent scent scent
i think it potentially elongates the s
noise
because if you say because i know
if you actually think about it i know
the difference between when you're
saying i
sent this to you or the scent
without without for when you said the
word scent i
just the way you said it i knew you were
talking about the smell i don't know how
i knew that
but i knew you were talking about the
smell rather than the word scent i sent
this to you
maybe maybe i'm thinking too deep into
it right
and like scissors you can't say you
don't say
like scissors you know what i mean it's
scissors
and what else is that there's sc there's
loads
scent scissors scene scene
and there's i seen this
the scene i don't know maybe maybe i'm
wrong
but i feel like there's just like a
millisecond
longer in the sc okay
um that helps you understand which
terminology someone was talking about
um but then again my boy's got a
clothing brand called
scene and the first time he told me it
was called scene
i didn't know what he was talking about
so maybe i'm wrong
and his scene is s-c-e-n-e right yeah
s-e-e-n-e-y
i didn't know i had no idea um
but yeah maybe i don't know i don't
think i have a feeling i just have a
feeling that none of them are silent
i feel like the the sc means something
because yeah scent scent is like
elongated s it's just not scent i
scent what's that scent
i'm not good at these linguistics i need
a
english language major to to jump in the
comments and be like bro you might have
fools
is this the federal actually knows yeah
because i don't want to google it but if
anyone actually knows
the answer if there is an answer please
bro literally
i don't even know man i don't even know
i saw that on
tick-tock on someone else's like clip on
the
from a podcast and i saw oh okay that's
fascinating yeah yeah
yeah i've never thought about that
before yeah yeah ever and for them to
bring that up thinking i'll show you
people on pods talk
high chat high chat tick tock pod clips
or high chat hijab some of them are
interesting some of them are like what
are you
on about i know wechat put but sometimes
bro
some people get into a mess of noise i
don't even know what they're on about
bro
um but that's interesting what's the
other one um i was gonna ask you do you
think
um strangers
are more inclined to tell so let's say
miyu for example
i should know let's say you when a
random but you meet a random person
um do you think you're more inclined to
tell them secrets than you are a close
friend
very good question but i'd be inclined
to tell a stranger my secrets more than
i would a close friend
okay let me give you like a more of a
let me give you like a scenario right
now
yeah let's say you're in a night out
yeah and you meet a ting
yeah but it's one of them ones where
it's not even you've both established
like
you're just here for bands it's not a
sex thing blah blah you've just
found a person you can actually have a
conversation with even though you're in
a club which is weird yeah but like the
conversation is just floating
like oh let's step outside you're like
i'm going to go out for a cigarette but
you're just going to
have a drink yeah and the conversation
is flowing and you're like
okay this is great this is very good
yeah yeah
but you start having you start she
starts reeling off some stuff to you
about random [ __ ] like random
stuff that you wouldn't even consider
should be part of this conversation yeah
and then you start doing the same as
well but stuff that you've held in
that you've wanted to tell someone but
you never wanted to tell somebody
like case in point when you said um
would you
when we talked about would you want to
know how you die or when you die and
then you say oh you wouldn't want to
tell your mum when you die yeah
yeah that's outside the immediate stuff
yes yes yes yes yes
so do you feel like in those kind of
situations you'd be more inclined to
tell people that you may not potentially
see again
certain things just to get off your
chest
potentially i think actually potentially
the reason i say potentially is because
i was actually listening to a podcast
with a guy called david cho
david cho is a very interesting guy
david cho is a guy who's like a street
artist
who now is super rich because he
um he did the
artwork in the facebook headquarters
okay
so he did the artwork in the facebook
headquarters originally the first
headquarters facebook ever had
okay so you know in the movie like the
social network and they move into that
big office and stuff like that it's got
graffiti all over the world
in the real life david cho is the artist
who actually did that
okay and he charged them i think he
charged him i might be wrong i think he
charged him like 60 grand
for the whole time yeah whoa what are
you
all right i spoke and i hiccuped
i could tell bro took me away that
sounded like your lungs collapsed
jesus sorry yeah so that's 60 grand for
the whole thing 60 grand for the whole
thing
and the guy who plays um the guy who
justin timberlake plays in that movie
i don't know um sean
sean parker maybe um yeah the guy who
who justin timberla plays said to the
david show in real life
uh i could give you the 60 grand or i
can
give you it in facebook stock okay
because maybe they were a bit cash dry
at the time he said i can give you 60
grams worth of facebook stuck
for some whatever reason david cho was
like all right man just
[ __ ] it i'll take the facebook stock um
a lot of money so i'm surprised he said
to that
so he said okay um yeah give me in
facebook stock
um gave it to him and said facebook
stock obviously facebook
took off he cashed it in however many
years later for 200 million
sold his stock for 200 million
so now he's rich rich but he's an artist
yeah and he's just richer than god so he
just does
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] with his life yeah
because there's nothing else to do yeah
um so he told a story on this podcast i
listened to him on
where he went hitchhiking i think it was
around america
he just i think this is the continue and
i'll tell you why
all right continue yeah he went
hitchhiking around america
and he said about all the confessions
that people have told him is this where
you got it that's the reason why i asked
you this question i really saw that
exact video on tick tock
really yeah yeah yeah so yeah and he was
talking about there
like he's had like murder confessions to
him like he said the first 10 minutes is
literally just
um normal chitchat yeah yeah
yeah and he said when they get into the
last few miles before he's about to drop
them off
they realize i'm never going to see this
[ __ ] guy again and they tell him i've
murdered a guy
he had another guy tell him that i was
going to he stayed at a guy's house and
then the guy told him i was going to
rape
you in the middle of the night like
crazy [ __ ]
that's crazy that it's the same i was
going to give that exact example
really exact that's really cool that's
really cool exact example
yeah that's really cool um that's crazy
and you saw where terry's caught you off
you saw the actual
i saw the actual podcast i listened to i
saw a little clip on tick tock front
yeah yeah yeah the whole podcast is
fascinating that's crazy he's a
fascinating dude you should listen to
the whole thing
or watch our thing fascinating guy um
and yeah he yeah he's talking about all
of that and uh so that's
that's funny that you say that's where
you got it from um so maybe i would
i think it will be more stuff like not
secrets
that like not secrets
i think i think it would be more like
guilty confessions
that i'd be more likely to tell someone
just like what you said about getting it
off your chest yeah
guilty confessions are probably more
likely to to get off my chest because
those are the stuff you physically
cannot tell someone you know yeah yeah
you cannot tell someone you know but you
have to tell someone someone you can't
it's going to eat away at you yeah so
if it's someone that you will never meet
again maybe not a ting in a club
yeah but in those kind of situations
where they have no idea who i
am we're in the middle of nowhere i'm
never gonna meet this person again
potentially i might actually just tell
them some [ __ ]
maybe i would that's crazy i don't know
what gateway confessions i'll tell them
but it's crazy yeah i think i think i
would too if i was in
do you think you'd ever um pick up a
hitchhiker
no it's my short answer [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no bro i would like to for the life
experience yeah for the
for the whole kind of romance of what
could this person bring to my life
what could they say that's so far
removed from my everyday life that i'm
like
it just leaves an impact on my life
forever that's what i'd want yeah i'd
want to pick up my hijacker and by the
time i've dropped them off i'm i've got
a whole new perspective on certain
things
but nah nah
nah i don't know what's gonna happen
fair enough would you
never in a million years i didn't even
pay attention to the people that give
out flyers
oh no you walk through that walk through
i will never pick up your tracker yeah
i'm not picking up a hitchhiker bro
never in a million years yeah especially
not in this day and age because this nh
hitchhiking's rare dude
and hitchhikers like for in this day and
age of someone's hitchhiking it's like
what happened bro yeah back in the day
in the 70s and 80s
people used to just do it to get around
it's just like oh we can pay
200 quid to go on this train or we can
hitchhike and have some fun there's
common mode of transport back yeah
they're like [ __ ] this hitchhiker
that's cool um my what a time to be
alive
would you ever if you were back in those
days would you ever like to try and
hitchhike
yes but not by myself yeah with someone
100 not by myself but yes it's something
i would love to i would have loved to
have tried yeah i lived back in those i
would definitely even in this day i
would definitely rather
hitchhike than pick up a hitchhiker yeah
yeah
okay let's say you're a hitchhiking oh
god yeah yes you're a hitchhiker
and um you flag down a truck
he's you're on a for example you're on a
motorway don't know how you got there
but you're on a motorway
and only only cars are coming past our
trucks
you hitch um you flag down a truck now
and he's like a he's like a middle-aged
white man
massive beard he's got a trucker hat on
he's missing a few teeth
let's say he's like a lorry driver for
like dhl for example yeah yeah yeah
yeah um and he's like oh where are you
going kid where are you going
um and you say i'm just going to i don't
know let's say you're going to
liverpool yeah for example um so he's
like oh yeah hop in blah blah hop and
hop and hop in
um you're going round going out y'all
thank you so much thank you so much
roblox you start exchanging like normal
pleasantries oh what's your name or
where you going or blah blah where are
you from and this that any other
and he's like he answers all the
questions everything seems normal
everything seems fine
and whilst you're driving he's got the
music up a bit loud
yeah and you hear like a
a little thud like a one of them ones
but you hear it but you question
yourself whether you heard it you know
what it was
yeah but it's coming from behind you
okay
it's coming from behind you yeah yeah
but you hear it but you don't
you don't react but you look out for his
reaction
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're looking
at him now but you're not making
quick movements you just look at him
yeah yeah and he's looking at you
you hear it right so you look at him
and because he's a bigger guy he's
looking down at you
just eyes gleaming and he's smiling
he's smiling you're bombing it now
you're on the motorway he's going 70
minimum what do you do
and then and then he turns it down
so i can hear it he wants me to hear it
now ask you to hear it
nah what do you do what do you do
he's got he's central lock the whole
thing he's central locked the whole
thing
you're in a you're in a 18-wheeler truck
there's people in the back
you're his next one what are you doing
nah fam
this whole look that this when i said it
scared myself
yeah bro i'll be terrified i think i
would have to just take a long
hard breath and just assume a character
that isn't myself
okay i would develop a personality
disorder like that
okay like that okay deal with this level
of fear yes yes yes yes yes yes so i
think i would have to
create an alter ego immediately yeah and
like
cool take a deep breath i'm like
and just just calmly be like cool
um bro
where do you want this to go yeah
where do you want this to go and and i
just explained the options briefly
eloquently cool obviously you want to
hear what's got you want me to hear
what's going on the back yeah
because i'm next yeah or whatever or
whatever the [ __ ] i don't care yeah
okay your business is your business
i don't know if you're a serial killer i
don't know if you're a human trafficker
yeah and to be honest
i don't care yeah yeah right this is
between you and i
yeah we're going 70 on the highway right
now yeah
here's how this is going to go you
either
let me out um
so you can either unlock that so here's
the options right you can either unlock
the door
i'm going to keep the door open until
you go slow enough that i can hop out
without dying
and then i don't know your license plate
number i don't know your name
i don't know where you're going yeah
yeah we leave it here yeah yeah
no one's the wiser i'll find another car
to hop into yeah everyone's fine
and you can deal with whatever the [ __ ]
you your kink is yeah you can deal with
it wherever you get your destination
yeah yeah yeah
or you can try and add me to the pile
and i swear to god if i catch you
slowing down
before i've opened this door i am
swinging this steering wheel big man
as hard as i can and everyone's dead
i swear to god i swear to god
we're all dead big man swinging the
steering wheel i'll say big man okay
here's the trick
you've got 10 seconds to unlock the ting
or i'm dragging this wheel down
your choice your choice bro
i i don't want to do this but
if you unlock this store in 10 seconds i
swear to god i'm pulling this wheel as
hard as i can
he says bet pull the steering wheel oh
100 pull it
if i can still hear the banging and he
dares me
dares me to hearing multiple bangs i
just walk
but now this is where the conscience
comes in you're about to
kill god knows i'm out okay
in this situation i promise you i don't
care who is this i
do not give a [ __ ] i don't care who is
this
i don't care who's watching okay who
here's this i don't give a [ __ ]
in that moment bro conscience conscience
i haven't got eyes written i haven't got
time for
any of that it's me or him they're
already dead
they're done for they should have
thought about that before they got in
this situation
it's me and him oh man says bet
you're gonna kill all these if he said
to me this is the thing is the thing
situation right
so i say mister yeah sir you either
unlock this door in the next 10 seconds
or i'm going to grab this wheel yeah
okay you play the guy
yeah okay and you say okay so i'm gonna
tell i'm gonna be me with my split
personality
you play the guy yeah you play the guy
right cool
so we'll react it re-enact it yeah yeah
yeah so we're driving driving driving
and we're having pleasantries i'm like
yeah
so just gonna go to liverpool man like
i'm a big fan of the beatles and stuff
and just want to check out all that
stuff
and then just um yeah so
i don't know just
[Music]
there's loads i'm just the driver just
looking at you
oh it's like one hunting i'm relaxed now
this is my comfort zone
okay right
dave can i call you dave you can call me
dave you can like
cool we all know what's going on
we all know what's going on right i
heard you lock the doors
yeah here's the dilemma
i don't i don't wanna i don't know
what's going on here
and frankly i don't care um i just want
to i just want to make it to liverpool
bro
i don't know your name real name i don't
know if everyone is dave plus you're a
[ __ ] white
lorry driver in middle england probably
half of you guys are called dave
i don't know where you're going and
where you came from i don't know
anything about you i don't know the
license plate number i don't know [ __ ]
all
right right so we've got two options
either unlock the door i'm gonna open it
and you slow down enough so that you
don't even have to stop i'm just to slow
down enough until i can jump out safely
and you can crack on with your merry old
day
or you've got 10 seconds to unlock the
door
or you're staring at me and it's scary
i'm not gonna lie to you i'm scared
or i'm gonna grab your steering wheel as
hard as i can
and kill us both what do you want to do
i'll keep driving b keep driving
if i'm dave to make you petrified fam
and i'll even put them put the music
back up and put the volume back up all
right all right cool
ten nine
oh i'm going eight i'm going bub
i'll be like dave you think it's a gay
you think it's a game
i'll be going you want to drag the filth
um the way i'd hold this theorem in will
yeah if i'm dave if i already know
i've got people in the back that you
know i don't care about my life anymore
fam let's go yeah i you're in my field
of expertise now
you live for this i live this is this is
what all of them said
that's what they all said this is what
they all said
and i've got 17 of them you're next you
call me dave you call me
phil because it doesn't matter anymore
you're not gonna remember tomorrow
you don't remember what my name is
tomorrow you're not gonna remember the
alias
you can do what you want big man
i'm driving confident
i'm driving with confidence
man bro i swear to [ __ ]
god you're dead bro
you're dead
jose bro i'm so happy you grabbed that
wheel you've made this so much easier
you're [ __ ] the whole 10 seconds i'll
be in your
ear with your mellow relaxed tone
that's so big you're [ __ ] dead bro
you don't even care
[ __ ] dead you're so
[ __ ] dead bro oh
bro i'm still gonna count to one and
when i do you best keep your hands there
bro because your head's going through
that [ __ ] window dude do you think
i'll give a [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] you're crying at this
point bro i'm sniffing
and i'm just there do you think i
[ __ ] care bro
this man oh you man of [ __ ] day oh my
days i hope you got your rocks off
before today big man
you should have kept it at 17. playboy i
promise you
you've got three seconds left unlock the
team
unlock the ting fan please i'm not gonna
ask you again
because i swear to god i will murder
everyone
and i'll have what you think i'd rather
go back there than die
i'm praying for death dave honestly
you're doing me a favor bro i've been on
the street for four weeks
i'm ready to go you're dead bro
just do us all the favor and unlock the
door why are you trying to be difficult
fam oh what a horrible situation a
horrible situation i'm not dealing with
that
i'm not dealing with actually swearing i
promise you now oh my god i'm not
dealing with that
oh thank you for that
thank you so much for that thank you so
much
that was hilarious i was there i was i
was dave how was that fam
when you said you did this thing you
meant when you said you can call me dave
you could call me joe
i felt it you encapsulated him you've
got demons bro
as soon as you said that i realized
alfie's got demons he's got tumors he's
thought about this long and hard
i was improving i was playing my role
i've never seen that side of you
you call me dave you can call me joey
one's got to go everyone's got to go and
let's wrap this up man all right gg
all right so this one is you guys
already know the drill uh this one is
food and drink
i've not done this one before oh jesus
i'm sweating
all right one's gotta go mcdonald's
kfc burger king nando's
mcdonald's but
mcdonald's kfc burger king or nando's
uh kfc oh bro
they've been shafting me as of late
they've been shafted me as a player i'm
sick of their antics
they can go say no good riddance
all right french toast yeah
waffles yeah crepes or american fluffy
pancakes
i believe we're not american fluffy
pancakes i'm not i prefer crepes a
million times a day
that's why i put crepes in there um
water hmm
tequila sip sip hmm jd and coke
monster oh oh genuine coke
okay because i'm getting to that point
in my life where
alcohol is functional for me now yeah
i'm only want to drink alcohol to be
drunk
yeah this whole like jd and coke is just
like a comforting experience for me
whereas i don't need that anymore yeah
just get me to where i need to be yeah
and i'll have to drink water for the
rest of the night yeah that makes sense
no i'm done with alcohol bro but say no
more um
ketchup barbecue sauce sweet and sour
sauce
mayonnaise mayonnaise yeah
okay last one coco pops
yeah frosties yeah cheerios
yeah crunchy nut normal cheerios yeah
no honey nut cheerios oh
and then crunching up with the chocolate
flakes oh
okay crunchy nut
honey nut cheerios frosting frosties
coco pops
frosties guys rusty's yeah yeah yeah
okay
one's gotta go mcdonald's
yeah burger king nando's mcdonald's
burger king nando's
you're not [ __ ] it mcdonald's can go
but i ride for burger king no one writes
for a birthday king hate burger king
no one writes a burger king burking is
legit i hate burger king
burger king with the first one with the
first one won't be the options
um waffles
french toast crepes
i think you'll pick that one
i think i'll pick the uh french toast
yeah that's what i picked yeah cool
um tequila sip sip monster
water sip sip right choice
ketchup barbecue sauce sweet and sour
sauce
ketchup barbecue sauce or sweet sour
sauce
sweet and sour sauce yeah that's it
cocoa pops cheerios crunchy nut
cocoa pops cheerios crunchy nut
uh you know what
coco pops okay they get soggy so quick
bro
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i heard
that i hate that let me get the other
one
cool last but not least one's got a goal
cool
burger king or nando's
burger king thank the lord if you pick
nando's
nando's is a whole meal bro nando's is
different you can't
i've had nanos in ages i've not had
when was the last time in nando's
probably when in our old yard
in my old year oh really probably last
summer yeah what would i mean you had it
probably oh okay
that is legit um one's got to go crepes
or waffles
that's waffles i love crepes bro
but then again those sugar waffles that
we used to get from asda
do the chocolate layer on top oh my god
they're
different they are different and i love
chicken and waffles and i hate
that's the thing as well i actually
prefer
those pre-made waffles that we used to
get from asda than fresh waffles that
you get from like a
like a thing i know what you mean i know
what you mean and
on the vice versa belgian waffles i
think that belgium offers the sugar much
prefer belgian waffles to like the
normal waffles you can get
um and i much prefer fresh crepes
to pre-made crepes are the most
disgusting things i don't think i've
ever had a premium
grim bro i never will buy a pre-made
crepe grim
um so you can see
so waffles are legit though man ice
cream on top
heated belgian waffle in the microwave
15 seconds
scoop of vanilla ice cream madagascar
vanilla
drizzle bruv i might stick with the
waffles
actually so crepes crabs
monster and water oh my word
that's like
[ __ ] cause i remember you dropped
monsters every day
yeah twice a day or something like twice
a day every day i drink a monster
i have done for years you've got a
monster [ __ ] pinball
thing yeah bro uh
i drink a lot of water as well i need
water to survive
monsters gotta go there because i need
water as a [ __ ] survivor what are we
even talking about
okay i thought you're gonna be stupid at
big water um
ketchup or barbecue sauce
frustrating enough bubble you saw scott
go wow because
it's just got more range yeah yeah you
can put ketchup on loads of [ __ ] i put i
could put barbecue sauce on anything
really anything that i could put ketchup
on i could put barbecue sauce on
i can anything some things like to be
fair
i had kfc the other week and i got the
hot wings
from kfc and i put barbecue sauce on it
and i was like
it needs ketchup it just some things i
just think are better with ketchup
and there's rarely something that i put
ketchup on that i choose to pick
up on that i'm like oh i wish i should
have buggy sauce on this okay i hear
that
i thought barbecue sauce works as more
as a like a coating
than a dip but yeah ketchup stays
okay and honey nut cheerios or
crunching up with the chocolate flakes
the clusters
clusters yeah crunchy nut clusters
they're tier one they stay
yeah so yeah yeah i could have told you
they were going to stay from the jump
conjunct clusters are a legit all right
so your final is you've got nando's
waffles water ketchup and
crunchiness clusters yeah bro i'll cut
you the clusters are teeth
where's the last thing we bought some of
those i buy them at least twice a month
bro
they're like three four pound a bag and
a bag gets you like two bowls
it's the smallest skinniest thing in the
world bro they're
they are expensive it's they're banging
though yeah they're unbelievable banging
i think i've eaten a bag in a day before
just back to back
they're too good yeah bro they're
bragging um but yeah man
let's wrap it up there all right guys um
we'll see you soon man yeah thank you
very much guys um
i hope you've had a good april and yeah
man love love love